STAYED OUTSIDE INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO STOP THE SUSPECT.
PETERSON
PETERSO
PETERSON, WHO HAS JUST RESIGNED,
BELIEVES HE DID A GOOD JOB ON
THIS.
HE IS ALSO A SHERIFF'S DEPUTY
HIMSELF. IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU,
SIR.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE NEW REPORTS THAT CAME OUT
NOW HAVE A TOTAL OF FOUR SHERIFF
DEPUTIES WHO DID NOT ENTER THAT
SCHOOL BUILDING AS THE SHOOTING
WAS TAKING PLACE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
TONIGHT?
>> I'VE HEARD RUMORS ABOUT THAT
REPORT MYSELF BUT I HAVE NOTHING
TO SUBSTANTIATE THAT ANY OF
THOSE CLAIMS ARE FACTUAL AT THIS
TIME.
>> PETERSON WAS APPARENTLY
BEHIND A VEHICLE WITH HIS GUN
DRAWN AT THE TIME THEY SHOWED UP
AT THE SCENE.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THE
PROTOCOL IS WITH THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVE SHOOTER SITUATION?
>> WELL, DEPUTY PETERSON BEING
THE FIRST OFFICER ON THE SCENE,
HE DID WHAT HE WAS SUPPOSED TO
DO.
HE CALLED IN OTHER SUPPORT,
UNITS ARRIVING FOR BACKUP.
BUT AT THAT POINT, HE STOPPED
THERE OF WHAT HE NEEDED TO DO.
AS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS, WE
KNOW THAT EVERY DAY WHEN WE GO
TO WORK, THAT THERE'S A CHANCE
THAT WE MAY NOT COME HOME TO OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND WE ACCEPT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WHEN WE HEAR AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER, I DON'T CARE IF IT'S
WITHIN A SCHOOL, A MALL, A HOUSE
OR AN OFFICE BUILDING, WHEN YOU
ARE THE FIRST PERSON THERE ON
SCENE, EVERY SECOND THAT YOU
DELAY GOING INTO THAT BUILDING
AND EVERY SINGLE GUNFIRE THAT
YOU HEAR FROM INSIDE THAT
BUILDING, THAT MEANS THERE'S
ANOTHER INNOCENT LIFE BEING LOST
AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE NOT TO GO
INSIDE THAT BUILDING.
WE KNOW THAT RISK WHEN WE PUT
THE UNIFORM ON EVERY DAY AND WE
HAVE TO LIVE UP TO THAT OATH.
>> AND DO YOU KNOW OFFICER
PETERSON?
>> NO, I DO NOT.
I'VE ONLY HAD ONE CONVERSATION
WITH HIM.
>> WHAT OCCURRED IN THAT
CONVERSATION?
>> JUST TO BRIEF HIM ABOUT WHAT
WAS ABOUT TO TRANSPIRE WITHIN
THE NEXT HOUR IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE MOVES THAT WERE
GOING TO HAPPEN, IN TERMS OF
BEING SUSPENDED WITHOUT PAY AND
AN INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATION WOULD START.
>> THE CORAL SPRINGS POLICE ARE
APPARENTLY THE ONES WHO ARE
TALKING.
AND THAT'S WHY WE GOT THIS NEW
DEPUTIES WHO SHOWED UP AND ALSO
DIDN'T ENTER THE BUILDING.
WHY WOULD THE CORAL SPRINGS
OFFICER EXPRESS THEIR
FRUSTRATION IF THEY HAD ENTERED
THE BUILDING OR IF THIS HADN'T
OCCURRED?
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE 17
DEAD AND WE HAVE MORE THAN A
WEEK HAS TRANSPIRED, WE STILL
DON'T HAVE THE CLEAR TICK TOCK
ON WHAT HAPPENED?
THAT SEEMS A LITTLE MUCH, DON'T
YOU THINK, GIVEN THE PUBLIC
OUTCRY HERE?
>> GIVEN THE PUBLIC OUTCRY, I
CAN SAY THERE WAS A LOT OF CHAOS
ON THE SCENE THAT NIGHT.
I DON'T DOUBT THE ACTIONS OF
SOME OF THE CORAL SPRINGS POLICE
OFFICERS THAT WERE THERE THAT
DAY.
HOWEVER, I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO COMMENT IF THOSE
ARE THE FIRST OFFICERS ON SCENE
OR IF THOSE OFFICERS THAT WENT
INTO THE BUILDING FIRST FROM
CORAL SPRINGS CAME OUT AND SAW
ADDITIONAL DEPUTIES.
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO COMMENT
ABOUT THAT AT THIS TIME.
>> SHERIFF ISRAEL BASICALLY
ECHOED WHAT YOU SAID, PETERSON
SHOULD HAVE ENGAGED THE SHOOTER.
YOU'RE THERE, SHOTS ARE RINGING
OUT.
YOU DON'T STAND OUTSIDE, YOU GO
IN.
THAT'S LIKE THE FIREFIGHTERS AT
9/11.
YOU GO IN THE BUILDING WHEN
EVERYONE ELSE IS LEAVING.
THAT'S YOUR JOB.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
THAT'S THE DANGER OF BEING A
POLICE OFFICER.
BUT YOU MADE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
SCHOOL BOARD IN BROWARD COUNTY
AND LAY BLAME ON THEM.
EXPLAIN THAT TO US.
>> YES, I DO.
I THINK THAT'S THE ONE ENTITY IN
THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION THAT HAS
NOT BEEN BROUGHT UP.
SOME OF THE FAULT OF PUT ON THE
BROWARD COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD.
FOR YEARS THEY KNOW THE SCHOOLS
ARE SOFT TARGETS.
THEY CLAIM THEY WANT TOUGHER
SECURITY BUT DON'T WANT TO COUGH
UP THE MONEY TO PAY FOR THE
SECURITY.
AND THEN WHEN THEY ARE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE A SCHOOL RESOURCE
DEPUTY ON SCENE, AN ARMED POLICE
PRESENCE, A LOT OF THE
LIBERAL-THINKING PRINCIPALS ON
CAMPUS THERE DON'T WANT THE
POLICE OFFICERS MAKING ARRESTS
ON CAMPUS AND DON'T WANT THE
DRUGS TO BE FOUND ON CAMPUS AND
DON'T WANT THE WARRANTS TO BE
SHOWN ON CAMPUS BECAUSE IT LOOKS
LIKE BAD STATS AT THE SCHOOL.
I PLACE A LOT OF THE BLAME AT
THE SCHOOL BOARD WITH THAT AND
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
NOBODY WANTS TO FILL THE JAILS
WITH JUVENILES.
EVERY POLICE OFFICER WILL AGREE
ON THAT.
THE PROMISE PROGRAM IS AN
INTERVENTION PROGRAM WHERE WE
STOP FILLING THE JAILS WITH KIDS
AND GET THEM INTO PROGRAMS.
WHEN THAT PROGRAM STARTED, WE
TOOK ALL DISCRETION AWAY FROM
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO
AFFECT AN ARREST IF WE CHOOSE
TO.
THERE'S A LOT OF PARENTS OUT
THERE SCREAMING FOR HELP IN
TERMS OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND FAMILY INTERVENTION FOR
SERVICES.
>> WE HAD 23 CALLS GO INTO THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE ABOUT
THIS FAMILY.
SOME WERE ABOUT NIKOLAS CRUZ'S
BROTHER, INCLUDING CALLS ABOUT
HIS POTENTIAL FOR VIOLENCE.
AGAIN, YOU'RE THE EXPERT HERE.
YOU REPRESENT THE UNION HERE.
BUT 23 CALLS TO ONE HOUSE AND
YOU ADD THAT WITH THE FBI TIPS
THEY GOT IN 2016 AND AS EARLY AS
IN NOVEMBER AND APPARENTLY
ANOTHER ONE IN FEBRUARY, THIS IS
RED FLAG AFTER RED FLAG AFTER
RED FLAG.
>> IT IS.
THEY ARE LOOKING INTO THAT RIGHT
NOW WITH THOSE CALLS, BUT I CAN
TELL YOU, IT'S NOT AN UNCOMMON
THING WHERE WE SPEND TWO, THREE,
FOUR, FIVE TIMES A WEEK THAT WE
RESPOND TO THE SAME HOUSE FOR
THE SAME PROBLEM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> SO YOUR LIMITATIONS ARE
WHAT?
YOU COULD SIT DOWN WITH NIKOLAS
CRUZ, CORRECT?
I IMAGINE -- HE DIDN'T SEEM TOO
BRIGHT.
I IMAGINE YOU COULD SIT DOWN AND
ASK HIM QUESTIONS.
CAN I LOOK AROUND?
DO YOU HAVE ANY GUNS?
CAN I SEE WHERE THEY ARE?
CAN I SEE WHERE THEY'RE STORED?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA IF THAT
TOOK PLACE?
>> I DO NOT.
>> THAT'S A PRETTY IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
>> I'M NOT PRIVILEGED TO
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE IT'S AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
I WOULD BE VIOLATING STATE
STATUTE BY COMMENTING ON THAT.
>> THE NRA DEMONIZATION THAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT NOW IS UNLIKE
ANYTHING I'VE EVER SEEN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO TAKE THEM OFF
TV, KILL THEIR BUSINESSES.
>> I FIRMLY BELIEVE THIS IS NOT
A GUN ISSUE.
I'VE SAID THIS FROM DAY ONE AND
HOLD THAT BELIEF UNTIL THE DAY I
DIE.
IT'S NOT THE GUN THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
THE
TH
IT'S THE PERSON BEHIND THE GUN.
I DON'T EVEN THINK THERE'S GOING
TO BE AN OUTCOME THAT WILL FIX
THIS PROBLEM, BECAUSE UNTIL WE
CAN LINK THE MENTAL HEALTH
RECORDS INTO THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WE DO TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM, WE WON'T SEE
IF A PERSON HAS A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE.
THAT HAS TO BE RESOLVED WITH THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND HIPAA
LAW VILLAGES
LAW VILLAGE
LAW VIOLAGE
LAW VIOLATE
LAW VIOLATIO
LAW VIOLATIONS
LAW VIOLATIONS.
>> SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID, WE NEED
LESS GUNS ON OUR STREETS, NOT